le sexisme le viol l'homophobie
l'inceste ont préféré les violences
faites aux enfants tous ces sujets on
les aborde - parce qu'ils dérangent
eh ben j'ai décidé d'en faire rire pour
qui ça arrange ça s'appelle l'humour
sérieux en fait j'utilise le rire pour
parler des sujets graves sensible tabou
ramener du monde et après débattre et
comme ma vie a été pleine de
rebondissements elle a été ma source
d'inspiration mais par des bus au début
j'ai fait de l'improvisation théâtrale
ça une équipe des thèmes on s'amuse
henry j'aimais me met les essuie glaces
bon là ils sont coincés
puis après j'ai voulu être seul sur
scène et je me suis dit mais je suis
lesbienne je vais monter sur scène et
par une mare relation de couple avec ma
chérie
qu'est-ce qu'on va rire ou pas dans
certaines régions de france
quand tu dis sur scène que tu es
lesbienne dans le public une armée de
suricates qui te regardent avec leurs
yeux rouges 7 est censé stimuler
l'imagination et fait réfléchir
mais leur imagination le stimule plus
elle s'arrête à plein de questions
elle a dit qu'elle était lesbienne tu
crois qu'elle se drogue
je sais pas elle a enlevé ses pires
signe avant de monter sur scène mais
c'est que quand elles sont âgées
qu'elles prennent du poids égal se coupe
les cheveux les clichés l'emportent
enfin les clichés l'ignorance
parce qu'après je suis allé au bar comme
ça me rendre à anvers et à monsieur qui
vient vers moi qui me fais est t'es
vraiment lesbiennes oui alors je te paye
pas un coup à boire
tu as raison parce que c'est contagieux
alors je vais toucher l'épaule j'ai fais
tu es gay croyez le ou pas il a fait un
mort et regarder sa main comme s'il
était lesbienne je suis lesbienne je
suis lesbienne au silo il applaudira
plus jamais comme avant c'est moi
j'allais la fleur au fusil
eh ben la vie de fan et 1 une fois dans
le sud de la france j'ai joué devant un
parterre de retraités pas un rire
pendant une heure talât chez les rames
tu regardes le moteur il ya plus
d'essence tu termines à la nage et j'ai
un sketch qui s'appelle l'orgasme
comme son nom l'indiqué je fais monter
un orgasme sur scène qui est censée
déclencher les rires voilà c'était plus
l'effet suricates c'était l'effet sourit
pas sais tu sortais lessivé un coup
d'adoucissant you lie et le lendemain
matin au petit déjeuner entre 3,40 flex
on m'annonce qu'à la pause
il ya des messieurs qui sont allés au
toilettes pour se toucher d'exceet on a
dû frotter les murs là ton bol de corn
flakes tu lui poses étudie mais quel
moment de wisches en train de vivre qui
a écrit le scénario
depuis je mange plus de complexes
mais j'ai continué persévérante la fille
une autre fois aux banques je joue il ya
un gars qui descendent des gradins qui
lève le poing et qui fut heureux ouais
je te montrerai et regarde moi salut
lesbienne je vais te montrer
excusez moi monsieur c'est pas le moment
de me montrer je joue mais regardez là
bas où il porte à l'est dû montrer à les
bisous alors j'ai raconté ça une amie
qui s'appelle mines et goodbye pour la
nommer qui organisait un colloque sur
les violences faites aux femmes
et elle m'a dit ben on donne quinze
minutes vient jouer ça et pareloup j'ai
alors réalisé que c'est possible de
parler des violences qu'on peut subir
qu'on a droit d'en faire rire et que ça
peut même ouvrir des débats
c'étaient les premiers pas de l'humour
sérieux j'ai alors rencontré la
fédération nationale solidarité femmes
qui est en charge de la plateforme du 39
je suis même devenu leur ambassadrice
c'est une histoire d'amour j'ai
rencontré des historiens des
historiennes des avocates des juristes
des psychologues des associations et
toutes ces données j'ai mixé à mon
humour et les couverts en stand-up pour
défendre les droits humains sont nés
et j part notamment de mes débuts et ces
gens que j'ai pu rencontrer
j'explique qu'ils n'étaient pas méchants
ils étaient ignorants et l'ignorance
rend bête et la bêtise peut mener à la
violence
ignorance bêtise violence le ricochet
des cons et j'explique aussi que dans la
rue quand tu tiens la main de ta chérie
tu les attire
ils sortent de partout aux deux
lesbiennes et c'est là qu'est ce qui
fait le mec belle fille on peut filmer
tu deviens un appât a ricoché je les
appelle les houga ou gars rien à voir
avec le marsupilami les ou cas c'est un
petit pourcentage des sommes qu'on pas
fini leur évolution darwin
ils en sont encore au début ils sont
dans les genoux comme ça ils peuvent
partir au ski ça rebondit dans leur
guise des trous pour gagner en souplesse
et la bouche toujours ouverte pour
respirer si nous oublie
[Applaudissements]
et quand deux lesbiennes se tiennent la
main devant à ouga et reste fidèle à
lui-même
oh oh oh
et d'un coup il vient parce qu'il veut
parler il veut savoir une fille vous est
lesbienne
non c'est ma soeur on va à la messe oh
je me disais aussi vous pouvez pas être
lesbienne vous êtes belle et toutes les
10 minutes qui en a un autre le fut vous
cherchez un truc à 3 il connaît depuis
deux centièmes de secondes et tu te
demandes si tu cherches un truc à 3
il s'allume en est on
non je cherche un restaurant o mais je
veux dire vous êtes bio fort multiprise
et quand tu leur envoie sa propre
ignorance et toi tu dois gagner un pari
ou des cons dissonance cognitive
j'arrive pas pensé essoufflé en même
temps va t'acheter une évolution
ignorance bêtise violence le ricochet
des con et tu peux même pas les ignorer
et puis je pense qu'il faut pas ignorer
l'ignorance parce que ignorance rend
bête et qu'elle peut mener à la violence
la seule force qu'on est à un autre
niveau c'est le partage
parlons de ce qu'on veut avec qui on
veut dès qu'on le sent
c'est la camisole de force des ignorants
parlons partageons pas ce que les
ignorants
ils s'approprient ces sujets là comme
une tache s'approprie un pull blanc
parle on partage on est que les
ricochets cool
j'ai alors commencé à jouer pour des
mairies elle me disait qu'avec des
thématiques comme les violences faites
aux femmes à le ramener pas beaucoup de
monde est bien là si parce qu'il ya des
gens qui étaient intéressés
il ya des gens qui étaient curieux de
savoir comment on fait rire de ça et les
gens qui étaient juste là pour passer un
bon moment et à la fin tout le monde
débat je vis des moments hallucinant
pour la ville de bordeaux je jouais
après médecins du monde qui présentait
un documentaire sur des hôpitaux qui les
ont mis en place en afrique pour
accueillir les femmes violées poignant
horrible le documentaire se termine par
une femme violée est une femme qui sera
à nouveau violé lumière dans la salle
et là une voix off qui fait et tout de
suite car elle chapet pied et ça m'a plu
parce qu'on peut voir l'horreur rire du
pire et après débattre c'est possible
j'ai joué à nice il ya une femme qui
était là qui était une femme battue elle
exprimé sa colère sa souffrance dont
elle me crier dessus mais il y avait des
gens du planning familial qui était là
elle a pu trouver l'aide
j'ai joué devant la communauté lgbt ya
toulouse
c'est incroyable que quand on rit de ce
qu'on peut subir après on parle la
parole c'est le début de l'action
et maintenant joue dans les entreprises
les entreprises
qu'est ce que j'adore
du concentré d'humains encore meilleur
que café pour tenir éveillé c'est le
nivellement par le haut
l'ascenseur qui élèvent l'ignorance
thing en dit long je suis tout éveillé
alors ça fait 15 ans que je travaille
dans les entreprises un j'anime les
réunions les séminaires par le rire puis
c'est compliqué technique plus mon
humour est affûté mais là en plus j'y
joue mes conférences stand-up
j'assiste à des débats entre
collaborateurs d'une profondeur et le
service diversité qui prend des notes
seiya pas quand on rit on est un peu
comme entre amis
et ça fait du bien tout se dire du coup
bah moi mon point de vue il augmente
d'entreprise en entreprise de ville en
ville comme un gros brainstorming
nationale je rencontre des gens hors du
commun je passe des moments incroyables
et c'est plus plus grands pieds dans le
nez aux pires moments que j'ai pu vivre
une langue en délit une autre et
l'humour c'est un langage universel
alors à la question peut-on rire de tout
je dis oui quand c'est le moment et là
c'est le moment ça vous dit qu'on rit
avant promis au riz
[Applaudissements]